esta vez nos dicen cuáles de las
siguientes funciones son continuas en x
igual a 3 y tengo gdx igual al logaritmo
natural de x menos 3 y fx igual a en
elevado a la x menos tres bien así que
qué te parece si recordamos lo que
dijimos en el vídeo anterior en el vídeo
anterior que lo tengo justo por acá
deseamos que una función es continuar am
si el límite de fx cuando existen de amd
es igual a efe
ésta era nuestra definición de
continuidad recuerdas
tenemos que estar definidos en ese punto
así que si regresamos a nuestro problema
de esta ocasión y me pregunto cuál de
estas funciones es continúan en x igual
a 3 entonces una función f es continua
en x igual a 3 siguiendo la misma lógica
de lo que vimos en el vídeo pasado
si sólo sí
el límite
cuando x tiende a 3 de fx de fx o deje
de x tiene que ser igual a efe de 3 y
bueno esto lo estoy diciendo porque lo
primero que quiero que evaluemos es
ambas funciones en x igual a 3 para ver
si están definidas o no así que primero
tratemos de evaluar de 3g de 3 y ahora
observa lo siguiente me quedaría el
logaritmo natural el logaritmo natural
de 3 menos 3 lo cual es el logaritmo
natural de 0 y esto no está definido
no puedes elevar a en alguna potencia
para obtener 0 puedes intentarlo y tal
vez le podrás decir bueno eso es menos
infinito pero eso no está definido
entonces si esto no está definido en x
igual a 3 no hay manera de que vaya a
ser continua en x igual a 3 y por lo
tanto podríamos descartar esta función
ahora qué pasa con fx bueno pues si
evaluamos f3f 3 si va a estar definido
esto es lo mismo que el elevado a la 3
menos 3 lo cual es a la 0 y al a cero es
igual a 1 y tiene toda la lógica del
mundo porque como ya vimos la función
exponencial está definida para todos los
números reales de hecho esta es una
versión desplazada de la equis y por lo
tanto va a permanecer continua pues es
continua en todos los números reales lo
que quiere decir que es continua en x
igual a 3 inclusive podría hacer esta
pequeña prueba el límite cuando extiende
a 3 de fx y que es esta función de clean
va a ser igual a efe de 3 que es elevado
a la cero lo cual es 1 entonces
efe es la única respuesta correcta y una
vez más es bueno pensar que es lo que
está pasando aquí de una manera visual a
ambas funciones son versiones
desplazadas por ejemplo esta es una
versión desplazada del logaritmo natural
de x y esta es una versión desplazada de
la función
así que si queremos dibujarlas se va a
ver más o menos así imagínate que por
aquí me tomo mi egg
y por aquí me tomó a mi eje x ok déjame
ponerles nombre este va a ser mi eje que
por aquí tengo a mi eje x y vamos a
tomarnos algunos valores 1 2 3 4 5 6 y
todos los demás y aquí me voy a tomar 1
2 3 4 ahora dije que ambas versiones
eran una función desplazada de sus
respectivas funciones así que aquí en x
igual a 3 tenemos lo siguiente va a
pasar algo bastante interesante por lo
tanto déjame poner una línea punteada
por aquí y primero veamos qué es lo que
pasa con gdx déjame hacer una pequeña
tabla para que lo veas y aquí tengo a x
y aquí tengo a gd x y vamos a tomarnos
un par de valores lo que pasa sin déjame
hacer esta tabla qué pasa si x vale
bueno si x vale 3
tenemos el logaritmo natural de hacer
que como vimos esto es tan indefinido y
por otra parte qué pasa si tomo el
logaritmo natural de 4 menos 3 es el
logaritmo natural de 1 bueno pues esto
es muy fácil esto es igual a cero
así que observa lo que está pasando en
tres estamos indefinidos y después aquí
cuando tomamos el valor de 4 estamos en
este punto de aquí así que esta gráfica
se va a ver más o menos así más o menos
así como pueden ver en tres tiene esta
discontinuidad y de hecho ni siquiera
está definida para valores menores que 3
y después se comporta como un logaritmo
natural ahora fx es bastante más fácil
de dibujar si piensas en fx y pensamos
en f3 bueno
efe de 3 quedamos que era 1 entonces efe
de 3 es 1 vamos a pasar por aquí y se va
a ver una función más o menos
más o menos así se va a hacer una
función más o menos así y bueno observa
esta es una función que no tiene saltos
que no tiene huecos que no te dan
discontinuidades y francamente es
continua para todos los números reales
así que seguro va a ser continua en x
igual a 3